hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie and today we're going to
implement implement some search feature
and we've done this way back in project
1 so well almost a year ago now maybe 10
months ago we started with project ones
it's been a long time so we're going to
take a look back at what we did in that
project and use that to help us get
started on this project so just to give
you a quick overview we're going to use
the WordPress REST API so we're not
going to use graph QL for this and the
reason is with the WP graph QL plug-in
you can't currently search across
different post types and we need to have
that so we have a lot of different post
types right now in our WordPress
installation and I don't really want the
user to have to pick a post type to
search with that's what we would have to
do or potentially we would have to like
when a search happened fire off a ton of
requests to every single post type with
graph QL and then get all the data back
from all those requests put it all
together and then show it's the user so
I think it's gonna be a lot easier to
just use the REST API to make the call
so there's a plugin that you can use for
the rest api that allows you to search
multiple post types so that's what we're
going to use so we'll check that out if
it doesn't make sense right now when we
get into it hopefully to make a little
bit more sense when you see it
and actually we're gonna do this may end
up being a two-part show so my work on
it today and tomorrow depending on how
long it takes so we are gonna have to
build a little bit of UI to display the
search results so I'll be happy today if
we can get just something basic showing
up we can always work on the UI later
but I just want to make sure that we can
make calls to the WordPress API and get
data back and just display something
even if it's just some titles of the
data and we'll have to work out we're
gonna have to work out where that data
goes like we'll direct them to a page
it's yeah it's gonna be a little bit
weird and I don't have all I don't have
it all figured out yet so hopefully we
can come to some type of you know
solution as we work through this so
before we get started just want to say a
few things for those of you who are new
maybe just watching for the first time
in this stream I'm doing my regular
day-to-day work as a front-end developer
at a small University so there will be
mistakes mistakes are actually probably
the unique part about this stream so we
do make mistakes but then we work
through the mistakes together if you're
watching and you have access to the live
chat feel free to put any questions that
you have in the chat or any suggestions
for me I'd take a lot of feedback from
you all and a lot of what you tell me
ends up in the project if you want to
check out the code for the project
there's a link in the description and
you can check it out everything's on
github everything's open-source feel
free to take any code from this project
and use it in your own projects if
you're looking to build up your
portfolio and would like some
open-source concert
Lucian's feel free to to submit a pull
request to this project there are issues
on this project and on a lot of other
projects that we've worked on in the
past you can take an issue and submit
pull requests on there don't worry if
you're not exactly sure what to do just
ask me and I'll help you out
and that's it that's all that I normally
say for this oh one more thing
we split up our coding into twenty five
minutes sessions so I'll set a timer if
you ask a question during that 25
minutes I probably won't see it but
after that 25 minutes is up I'll take a
little break and then I'll answer the
questions so please be patient when
answering when asking questions I will
get to all the questions before I on the
stream unless some emergency thing comes
up and I have to end it but if you can
stick around to the end or you can ask a
question and then if you have to go
that's cool and you can always watch the
recording they are available the
recordings are available just a few
minutes after the stream ends here on
the pre-code camp youtube channel ok so
let me switch my screen and I said we're
gonna start out in the repository for
one of the projects we did a while ago
and it's CI reacts and we're going to
check out how we implemented a similar
search function here and then see if we
can use a lot of that code in our
project that we'll work on today see
pages
resources in dependencies okay we
actually have this on earth you if you
see this this is kind of cool that this
pops up but it says there's a
vulnerability in one of our dependencies
so we are we've already fixed this in a
branch
we just haven't merged that into master
yet so just once you know I'm not
ignoring this so this this was actually
fixed in another branch before this
warning ever even came up but that will
be merged into master hopefully soon all
right so let me see where you chills
okay so what we might want to grab this
utility as well let's see how we're
doing this and Maki
is there we are festive search-term
debounce soars nice okay so we have a
lot here and this is all I was a little
bit afraid that there would have been
jQuery in this because we did have a bit
of jQuery in this project so it looks
like there is no jQuery very happy about
that so okay we have a lot of filters
and things that are going on I may bring
over all of this because eventually I
would like to implement some filters in
the search but you probably won't get to
that today but I'll bring it over anyway
and then we can just you'll hook those
up into UI elements when we're ready for
it make sure whoops I forgot to start
the timer okay so I'm starting the timer
now and while I'm copying and pasting
this I I want to ask you Oh has anyone
done anything with blockchain coding so
I'm talking about like what crypto
currencies are based on so I recently
started doing just some really basic
tutorial coding with etherium and it
seems pretty cool and there's a
JavaScript library that lets you work
with that in any a JavaScript app so I'm
interested if anybody else is into that
or done any work with let me know in the
in the live chat or if you're watching
this later on let me know in the
comments if you if you are working with
it I'd like to hear what kind of things
you're doing with that especially if
you're using using it with JavaScript as
well alright so I don't need
new categories
okay I think this is all I need just go
over here I was working on the routing
so I I said yesterday I would be working
on the routing a lot and that's exactly
what I'm doing
so what we'll do is let's make another I
haven't decided exactly how we're gonna
display search results so for now I'm
gonna make another page component and
we'll do everything there I have some
ideas where we may not have a separate
page but we'll see so let's do a new
file and let's call this search a s and
let me let's go to here to our untitled
page where we just throw things when we
need to and we'll grab let's see this
just to give us some boilerplate
and let's get rid of that side and we'll
copy this move this over give us some
space okay so we won't need the query
we'll get rid of that and we can keep
our head header here and you know it
actually let's should we keep this it
alright let's keep the CSS for now let's
get rid of really our Evaro all of our
Apollo stuff we don't need the query we
don't need with data okay let's get rid
of this and oops I put those in the
wrong spot
and
we actually won't need that at least not
right now and let's we're gonna probably
need to bring in some stuff as well so
we'd be copying pasting a bit more let's
save that and let's see yeah so we have
this get get json utility so let's bring
that over and we even be bounced as well
so we'll need to bring in low - d bounce
okay and maybe we'll use yeah you know
what i'm not i think we're using
something different yeah we use material
you are materialized CSS so i can't use
these UI components over again at least
not easily all right so let's find this
log or this gay json so you chose and
fetch okay
do we have a utility photo right now I
don't think we do okay well let's make
that folder then folder and within this
folder then we're gonna make a new file
and we're gonna call this fetch and we
are going to save that now this was made
with some earlier versions of a lot of
things so hopefully this all still works
right
and we shouldn't need to do anything
else with that for now
yes learning the law let's get rid of
that okay oh and we need lodash debounce
so I just want to verify in our package
JSON what we brought over and I am I'm
just kind of moving around really fast
so please ask questions if you have any
questions I'm happy to slow down and
kind of review things it kind of in a
little bit more depth and explaining
what I'm doing and after saying that I'm
gonna glanced quickly at the live chat
to see if anyone's asking questions
about what we're doing right now
okay I don't think I see anything about
this right now so I do see some
responses to what I asked earlier about
blockchain stuff and when we take our
first break we'll get to that okay so
what did we okay so low - debounce cool
so low - has a lot of helpers and things
you can use but a cool thing is that you
don't need to bring in all of low - so
in this case we just want debounce so
we're just going to bring in D bonds I
think that's really awesome that we
don't have to pull in you know
everything if we're only going to use
one thing so we're gonna do yarn add and
what else we gonna do sorry I just I was
thinking about something I did earlier
and I realized I forgot to commit what I
was doing before I started the stream it
should be okay I just added a few routes
in the router so it's not it's not a big
deal all right okay so now we should
have everything that we need here for
these things to work but right now we
we're not we really don't have anything
going on here was this new JSON
[Music]
oh okay cool I didn't mean to bring this
over but this is actually what we're
gonna use here so I'm I'm glad that I
brought this over because this needs to
go up here so search term is gonna go
but let me put this in up here so we can
split it apart so for now this is where
Vivi - there we go so we're gonna put
this in here and then let's do search
okay and I had tested this out with a
search term Catholic since this is a
Catholic school I figured that would
give me some results and let me fill in
the rest here okay so what what's
happening here is that we're using this
multiple post type search so I am going
to take a second here to explain what's
going on so we're using fetch which if
you've never used fetch but you have
done some work with JavaScript this this
is like it's xhr so if you're familiar
that or if you've used jQuery what's a
clone jQuery AJAX then there's also
libraries like Axios that'll help you do
these types of requests but basically
you can request data without a page
refresh it's really nice for you know
form submissions or in this case
searching so we're gonna make one of
those calls and right now we're giving
it the URL so this is the the base URL
to access the WordPress sorry uh-huh
this is the base URL to access the
WordPress API and the WordPress ap got
API comes standard with WordPress now so
it's not a separate plug-in like it used
to be if you have WordPress installed
you have the API as long as you have one
of the newer versions of WordPress so
we've installed in WordPress the
multiple post type plug-in which allows
us to search multiple post types so
right now we're doing we're searching of
any posts that has a type of page any
one that has the type of
pages anyone that has the type of chapel
pages this is just a test
We certainly have way more post types
and we're gonna end up with a really
long URL here but for now this is enough
for us to to at least test things up and
see okay so now we're just gonna call
get JSON all right what takes us back to
that utility that we had which is simply
just kind of a wrapper around fetch and
it's going to give us back the results
in JSON format which is nice we can work
well with with JSON so you just pass in
that entire URL and then we're saving it
to state so now within state we'll have
data and we can access data the reason I
would pass this I would set this as
state is that we'll get a refresh so as
soon as state updates will automatically
rerender that component so as soon as we
get the data back it'll trigger the
rerender so this allows us you know to
immediately show the results it's kind
of nice I I don't know if you've ever
done anything like this and tried to
work it out with jQuery but there's
always issues with like when does the
data come and you know if you want to do
different things with elements on the
page like making sure the timing is
right and everything happens so that you
don't end up trying to select an element
that doesn't even exist yet so with this
you know with react we don't worry about
the data comes in and then now we do a
rerender with this data so some of the
other things that we're doing with this
is we're doing a debounce search so we
don't have a I didn't put in a search
input yet but what will happen with
search input is it'll run these searches
while you're typing so we don't want it
to run like
constantly that would make way too many
calls so what we're doing is just kind
of slowing down like how many searches
happen and you can check out the lodash
debounce page so if you type in lo - D
balance you can get all the more
information about exactly how that works
all cool no way I didn't realize that
this would tell me so anyway Visual
Studio code is telling me a lot of stuff
about debounce and it's telling me the
parameters this is insane how did I not
notice this stuff before this is so
useful Wow Wow it even gives me saying
check out this article for more
information wow so crazy Wow did anybody
else realize that okay so we're getting
results results this this might make
more sense once we actually put the
input in but okay so on submit the first
thing we're doing is preventing the
default behavior all right which makes
sense because we don't normally a submit
of a form causes a page refresh but we
don't want that to happen right so we
got to prevent that and then we're gonna
actually start the search so you can see
down here we have this fetch search term
and if we take the value of that search
input which we will make and then we run
this right I'm gonna skip over a lot of
these filters because we're not gonna
use them yet
yeah so shows okay so this happens on
submit' but then we also call this on
while on the on change event so while
we're typing this debounce search gets
cold and it'll also run this fetch
search term and I think I probably would
have named this differently if I was
doing it again but anyway there's we're
not fetching the search term we have the
search term we're actually running the
search but anyway I'm uh gonna rename it
right now all right so I'm gonna check
how much time we have in this session so
okay cool we have enough time so let's
build out a little bit of the the UI so
that we can enter in some data and do a
search and then get some of that data
back okay B I should yeah let me see if
I can copy and paste a lot of what we
have in in this repository now as I
mentioned earlier we're using a totally
different UI framework but for testing
purposes I can probably just copy and
paste some stuff over the styles won't
work but it should at least let us do a
search and then we can work out how to
make it look pretty after we know that
it works so pages resources let's check
this
whereas a search okay here's our form
nice okay
I think that's all we need
cool alright let's paste this in here
and let's see how this looks
and let me see if I can just go to the
search page if it'll let that happen
nope okay so our
yeah so we're gonna have to change the
router a bit to let direct this page
where it needs to go hmm I haven't
thought about this
and we're doing the router before so
server da Jas file so let's see see how
we need to do this
I don't think this will work just like
that let's sort the shot whoa what did I
do
oops you know what I forgot to share the
anger uplink today so I'm gonna share
that as well
and your export you use compose maybe
that's just not important maybe
okay yeah it's trying to get search
pages export kiss Jason was not found
and he's so switch
hmm
all right so
compose is not defined just 101 okay
oops compose shoot do I need to bring in
compose
with Apollo I don't think I need to
area okay I've forgotten that cool all
right so search I wonder if I need this
is the most terrible looking search
thing I've ever seen
all right but we do have the search okay
so let's let's console.log our data so
let's console.log this state data whoops
what am i doing this state data
so let's make sure our console is open
okay so fetch failed loading
okay but it did try to search for the
okay
so why is this not working
interesting well you're not getting
anything but this works all right so our
our strain to search isn't working so
that's what we'll do
right after a five minute timer here and
let me scroll up and answer as many
questions as I can and let's see we have
like double the viewers that we had the
last time I checked so welcome everyone
if you're joining me before I or after I
did the the intro so we're gonna do five
minutes of question answer then we'll go
back into another 25-minute session of
coding and if you happen to missed
anything don't worry you can always
watch the recording and and figure out
what you know what we did at the
beginning
Fidel's says will you use the latest
features of reacts such as fragment and
report or anything for the latest you
know what I try to use the latest
features like number one if if I hear
about them and I read about them when
they first come out which I don't always
have time to do but I try and then if
there's an opportunity to use them in
the project I try to so today probably
won't be using any of those but you know
we have done that in in previous streams
sometimes we've we usually update to
newer new versions of things immediately
and try out you know whatever new stuff
makes sense to try out in our projects
we have Renato says good afternoon from
Brazil and noble savage commented before
the stream even started beard with lots
of exclamation points and the the bot
the bot banned them for five seconds for
it but yes my beard is getting a little
bit bushier
and I knew yesterday who was it Michael
mention that in the last video that I
did on my channel you can see all the
gray hair in my beard a lot so is that
you did anybody watch that video is it
really bad with the gray hair let me
know I mean I I'm okay I'm not worried
about my gray hair I worry more about
the lack of hair up here than the gray
hair down here my kids told me yesterday
that I have a lot of hair except on my
head so I immediately told my Amazon
echo I said Alexa buy Rogaine and let
that's like a medicine that's supposed
to help you grow hey I didn't really buy
it but I was tempted to let's see Nicki
says this bracket syntax for react
fragments work and create react app yet
or do you have to write react off
fragment YouTube chat won't let me post
the actual syntax I don't know I don't
know that we did we try it and create
react app yet I don't think we tried it
and create react app Nicki says asks
about so I was talking about a theory
I'm coding and so it's like blockchain
and the saying are you using a special
language just even gritter has a course
on udemy for blockchain aetherium coding
so yeah the language
let me scroll over and see what language
it was I don't even remember no shoot
all right so the the tutorial that I was
doing is called crypto zombies
so it's crypto zombies io which it just
seemed kind of fun like it's kind of
like a game and you learn as you build
out these characters in the game so
that's what I'm using so if anybody's
interested in doing that with me check
out crypto zombies dot IO and so so far
I'm only done with like the first
like course so I've created one zombie
but it was kind of cool it's pretty easy
to learn it's definitely a little bit
more rigid than JavaScript like you have
to define a lot more like beforehand but
it's not too hard if you already know
about JavaScript you'd be able to fly
through you know the first lesson I did
the first lesson this like this morning
and I don't like less than a half an
hour
ABI shakes his basic blockchain here as
well
using javascript not something that I
really worked on we'd love to contribute
though cool David asked what tutorial
was going through so I guess I just
answered that solidity that's it
Nicki's Nikki has it the name of the
language is solidity so that's what I've
been been learning all right so the
timer's let me write down where I got to
in the chat which may be about halfway
through the chat so didn't do that low
and getting through but we'll get to the
rest of it after the next Pomodoro
session
okay so what are we doing okay this
doesn't work let's figure out why this
doesn't work so I am going to go over to
the plugins that I have in WordPress and
make sure that that plug-in is there and
it's activated it is don't you eat you
folks if you alright so let's take this
down multiple post type
all right I am going to copy and paste
the example
and let me verify that that is the right
IPA just 104 two three six four one five
nine okay that is the right IP slug
about me let's take this just say about
let's try the example was the exemplar
Catholic and we're not gonna do page
let's do type
yeah we should be able to do tape
the shy major let me bring up do I have
the post type so I don't think I have
them up I have that custom plug-in and
that tells me what all my types are so
on my other screen I'm going to bring up
that custom plugin so I can just view
what types we have make sure I get the
the correct names so we
so you shall arrest directories so we do
the directories for rest and what's the
next thing news okay so those are types
that we do have
alright this is not good this did work
alright I actually have let me pull this
over just to show you so I tested this
out earlier and it did work so oh that's
what's different it's saying slug here
but we did search so let me change this
there we go ok so if we do search it
works alright let's go back to our code
and see where I messed this up
so search alright so in here it actually
it does work let's verify let me refresh
that ok so this should work and this was
the same let me make sure I didn't mess
anything up actually I could check the
this this will show us what we actually
used HTTP colon slash slash
question mark search and type equals
pose
okay all right so it looks like we have
the right the right thing being searched
for maybe actually I think I have an
idea
I mean I'm gonna check the live chat see
what y'all think
well yeah a whole conversation is going
on in other languages all right Michael
Creole says check search is 32 so it's
line 32
[Music]
so it's this D bounced search cancel
hmm
okay all right so Michael said checking
the error log
let me get rid of this
then we try this before copying it in
there we didn't get anything okay so
maybe there is something wrong with this
all right let me check them right next
to each other multiple posts that
question works it was
that's crazy they're the same
all right let me do this I'm gonna copy
and paste this right here
so it is going to search this let me
save it just to see what we can get here
so when we hit search
okay
all right what am I
oh there is something different right
yeah there's something different between
the two of these what is it
alright I'm checking the live chat now
you have an extra s Chappell page it may
mayor that you're right I do have the
extra s but it looks like it looks like
it works either way of those so I I mean
at least in the browser it could work
with or without the S yeah it works with
or without the S okay so
all right here's what I should be able
to do I should be able to figure out at
what point it stops being the same with
like this there we go there it is
admissions page instead of admissions
pages let's see which one is admissions
page all right so let's see
come on
ok so now we at least know that our our
string here for the URL it does work in
the browser so it's just not working
here all right okay so yeah just to
verify oops let's remove this yep and
they are the same now okay so let's take
this up and take this out well actually
let me let me just go back there we are
and admissions pages and chapel I'm an
admissions page and Chapel page okay
let's see
all right cool hey Harsha what's up
we're just get chase on defined let's
see
so get JSON we're bringing it in up here
in utils folder so let's bring it up
area get JSON
you import isomorphic fetch is the Ito's
fetch import correct yeah I don't all
right let's let me look at this Aragon
okay so we are attempting to make a get
request right
the import fetch from isomorphic fetch
Narsingh expand get function are [ __ ]
let me let me give you the the end rot
link to in case you wanna check that out
hey we got it to work
okay cool
alright let's put some of this data in
here
title rendered alright let's try to get
a title rendered for each of these nikki
says so what was the Tet the fix I alts
have for a second I don't even know I
don't know what I I think the problem
was I kept searching for just some
nonsense and so I was getting back an
empty array and then when I search for a
term that I knew would give a result
then I got a result so I could let me
yeah that was fetch failed fetch failed
yeah actually it keeps telling me it
failed no matter what but if you look at
the network I get status 200 okay
success true I don't I don't know what's
happening here
III don't understand all right well
let's just display a little bit of this
quickly so I don't have much time in
this session so let me just go to go
here and say oops um I don't need that
I'm in the layout so let's see
all right so I'm not talking cuz I'm
just trying to get this done before the
timer comes up so key items how to
render okay
okay cool there we go all right it works
all right so I can't believe I got that
in before the time ran out all right so
here's here's what I did I just said if
this state data exists then I want you
to map over all the items so remember
this state data is an array of objects
so I want you to map over everything and
then we just use an arrow function so
it's going to be inside this map so for
each item that's gonna represent a
different object so I just did a div I
put a key on there or else react
complains that there's no key so I just
use the ID and then since I'm used to
using the WordPress API I knew exactly
where this was which which helped so
item title rendered gave us the data we
needed so now when we search we get the
titles so let's try it out with a
different search term Chappell awesome
so Chappell and students great so we're
getting different search items based on
that why are we only always getting ten
all right I'll have to work on that but
basically it worked we have a search
function now we can't do that much with
it but we have it and it works so
awesome so now let me go back to where I
was in the live chat where I left off
that last time and I'm gonna go through
I'm gonna go through all the rest of the
questions mr. Tommy yeah I'm gonna go
through all the rest if you have a
question or comment please put in the
live chat now and I will I'll get to
everything in the live chat so the
coding portion of this is pretty much
over
we depending on what questions are we
may go back to the code and do a thing
or two but for the most we're not gonna
do a whole other point or a session of
coding maybe tomorrow we'll go back to
this and build out the UI and build out
some of those filtering options because
I want you to be able to be fill to
filter this stuff like you're at
amazon.com right
I want users to be able to just narrowly
filter everything to get exactly what
they want so actually not I think about
it that might be more than one more
stream to make all that happen but about
will probably work on it frog for the
rest of the week and that's something
else more important comes up Alexi says
hello Jesse are you leveling up as a
programmer I think I am I think I'm
learning more every day so that's all we
can do right just try to keep learning
and and keep going what we can so yeah I
guess I'm leveling up slowly but surely
I don't know but you all let me know
does it seem like I'm a better
programmer now then a few months ago or
or have I gone downhill in my past my
prime yet Alexi says you look like a
wizard with that beard cool I will I
take that as a compliment I like the
there's something relaxing about just
being able to just stroke your beard
like this my wife thinks it's weird she
just laughs at me but it's fine and it
does protect your face a little bit from
the cold and from babies who try to grab
your face and give you like battle scars
like this one they go to grab your face
instead they get a handful of beard so
it's definitely functional as well as
fashionable every shake says where you
copying code from sorry I haven't been
that involved with this whole process in
the beginning oh okay
Oh Annie he answered it already it's a
good answer so Nicky says he's taking
the code from a previous project he's
done it's C I react on github yeah that
is so on if you wanted to check out the
project we are copying things from at
the beginning it's CI - react on the
github repository that we work from so
it's it's a what's it called
organization repository so fu fu s -
marcom M AR CLM is the repository so my
personal github is separate from that
although I'm the the owner of the
repository I guess yeah but you check
out there and it's also project one in
our series of videos so if you want to
watch any of the videos when we first
implemented that search function you
could go back and check that out trying
to think not all of my videos are titled
well but I think I did put descriptive
titles for that first project
Aniki asks how does isomorphic fetch
differ from regular fetch so isomorphic
fetch so regular fetch works in the
browser I mean assuming you have a newer
browser where you can polyfill it
isomorphic fetch works in on the server
with with node so that's why we're using
isomorphic fetch as well in kind of
thing hmm so we probably didn't need to
use it here because this is all
happening client-side not server-side
but the project where I copied it from
we were actually making client and
server-side calls not for the search but
for loading some other data so that's
why it was using isomorphic fetch so we
didn't really need to do that but I mean
it's nice to have that utility if we do
need to use it you know we can use it
server-side as well since we're using
next we can use it in inside that that
props would it lose that function called
I can't remember is it props something
what is it called
and we're not using it here or we using
this get initial props function that
comes with neck so things in here will
run server side and client side
Raphael says good afternoon from
Venezuela welcome thanks for watching
Victoria says where is the past video
tutorial help ok so we have a lot of
other videos so there's a playlist on
the free code camp YouTube channel
called live coding with Jesse that has
all the videos it's a lot of videos
right now so I'm not really sure how
you'd want to go about watching them I
would say maybe just check out the
titles and watch one of the videos that
seems interesting to you based on the
title also people have told me that it
helps to watch the video at like 2 times
speed and then just to slow it down if
there's something you're really
interested in and I'll recommend that I
tried it as well I think the videos when
you're watching the recording are much
better at a faster speed it makes me
look better because I type really fast
and I talk really fast
if you've set it on a faster speed
let's see John says fetch and react is
so much easier than jQuery AJAX call
yeah I agree I think fetch is the
easiest way to make Network requests
Abhishek says fetch is polyfill for
browsers which don't have fetch function
it adds fetch function to your browser
dice amorphic to your browser period
isomorphic is implementation of fetch
for both no GS and browser on top of the
technical alright yeah exactly
so Abhishek was answering the question
about the difference between regular
fetch and isomorphic fetch so that's
exactly right the crap Pathan says I
just got here what's so amazing Visual
Studio code is amazing when what it
where was it
with debounce so if I hover over
debounce
it gives me all this information about
the bounce it lets me know what it does
and then it also says it recommends an
article for me to get more information
it gives me all the parameters that I
could possibly use and it describes what
they do it's really cool right it's
right there I mean normally I just look
it up on my other screen but being right
there is really awesome
michael says isn't that up to the author
of the extension to write I'm guessing
that that is the case I mean I I don't I
really don't think Visual Studio code is
going out and like searching for this so
I'd imagine that's the case but either
way it's really cool that this pops up
and if it is the the author of this
extension then good job on that thank
you
that's awesome feature John says with
that revelation of amazing code feedback
in BS code it looks like I may change my
editor yeah I mean that that's a really
nice feature alright was so there's a
lot of conversation back and forth in a
different alphabet than I use so I'm not
gonna try to translate all of that if
anybody wants to if any of those
questions were directed to me then let
me know but it's just a lot to go
through and translate right now so I'm
not I'm not gonna do that on the stream
I might go after the stream and
translate everything
Michael earlier I mentioned that Michael
had said that you could see my gray hair
and my the latest video so I I didn't
think I've talked about I didn't mention
with the video was so I just went on an
interview I interviewed for a position
as a full-stack engineer and I did a
video on my own YouTube channel which is
linked in the description just
explaining what the interview was like
and then giving some of my thoughts and
advice on coding interviews so if you're
interested please check that video out
and Michael says it wasn't as bad as or
no wasn't it Michael says it was only a
hair or two Nicky says not as bad as I
thought was quite disappointed about
that yeah so I don't have that much gray
hair you can't really tell in these
videos the resolutions not as high but
the other video I did was a better
camera and so you
I guess you could tell they said the
grey hair doesn't bother me then less
hair on my head bothers me a lot more
okay John says that the new bracket
syntax for fragments does not yet work
and create react okay good to know so I
do have some projects that I haven't
create react apps some of them we have
using next so that's just something
we're going to have to keep in mind if
we use that to make sure we we think
about okay what what are we using with
this project will it work okay
curious truth asks how much time should
I put into CSS early on I actually
really dislike it so I'm really having
to force myself to work with it and
inevitably end up procrastinating I
would say and I'm gonna read out some of
the answers as well but that others have
given but I would say this depending on
what you want to do CSS might not be
that important for you if you really
want to be a front-end developer you are
gonna didn't need to know some CSS but
you can get away with using some
frameworks and focus more on JavaScript
and you'll be okay with that and
depending on where you work you may be
able to get away with that even more if
you want to do more of like back-end or
even be like full stack with a back-end
focus then you're probably safe to skip
over a lot of CSS stuff and just do
focus more on JavaScript so it just kind
of depends on how much friend do you
want to do and then what would job so I
guess right now if CSS is holding you
back from learning more you're fine to
just focus more on JavaScript but if you
start to have to have a job that you
really wants and you need to use it of
course you're gonna have to learn that
but not every developer job are you even
going to need to use CSS that much if
they already have a style guide or
certain framework that they use you may
not even have a
freedom to do very much with CSS so it
may not be a big deal depending on who
else you have on your team
so if you if you're gonna do like
freelance stuff and you're going to be
expected to do everything on a project
then you're gonna need to know CSS so in
anyway hopefully that's a decent answer
let's see what what everyone else said
John says it depends on your goals what
kind of developer you want to be CSS as
part of the whole design and function
process pretty important to have a
fairly good understanding okay so also
good answer
okay so old sauce is explained a little
bit about what what they are talking
about and I wonder
I'm not exactly sure what language that
is like I don't want to know now but
basically it was just someone asking
about like what I was talking about so
far okay it's Russian so it looked like
Russian
hm
see
Michael Michael put like a little like
laughing crying emoji saying we'll be
will rebuild Amazon search tomorrow yeah
I didn't I didn't realize that when I
said it but you're right that does sound
ridiculous that I'm gonna do it just
like Amazon say I'm not it wasn't my
intention
Amazon search is way too advanced for
what we're gonna do it but we're we're
gonna try to make our search more like
Amazon search let's see
hard should ask if I can test messaging
in JavaScript AF which is one of our
side projects yeah I could test the
messaging and if Michael says the day
after that we'll refine Google's
algorithm alright jr. says hello from
Africa from Senegal I love your live
coding Oh awesome thanks for saying that
thanks for watching that means a lot
when when you all say things like that I
appreciate it
oh it's so harsh it is saying that most
mature packages right those like this
kind of thing now if it'll so that's
really cool I'm gonna have to kind of
try to do this more and hover over
things and just see like what would
extra info I think this is really useful
it may be able to get like extra
functionality out of things whereas
normally I would just use what I I know
and wouldn't take the extra time to look
it up you know but this is so convenient
you know I may be able to find a
parameter that may give me a something
better that's cool I like that world
says you're only like 30 why do you have
gray hairs already I don't know I'm 32 I
don't know why like I'm losing my hair
on the top and I have gray hair and my
beard like what is I don't know what
what's wrong with that it's like anyway
yeah maybe it's the kids I do have four
kids and so maybe maybe they cause my
grade you know what it was I used to
teach high school that's what did I'm
convinced that's what did it I taught
high school for like almost four years
that must be it does that is teaching
high school students is super stressful
it's so stressful so I'm gonna blame it
on that I mean maybe I could blame it on
semicolons but now that I use you know
standard style I don't have semicolons
so I'm a lot more relaxed
all right well I have made it to the end
of the live chat horseshit I see I was
just reminding me to test the messaging
I will I will do my best to test the
messenger okay so I'll be back tomorrow
I don't think we have not we I don't
think I have any meetings going on
tomorrow so should be able to stream at
the normal time and we'll be working on
this search again and refining it a bit
in the meantime I'm just going to be
adding new things to our routing
functions so you get more of the site
accessible from the proper URLs and I'll
be working on making sure all the data
is formatted correctly in WordPress or
as correctly as we can get it at this
point so in the meantime if you have any
questions you can always reach out to me
on Twitter or Instagram or Facebook or
wherever else you can find me or comment
in this video if you if you're
interested at all in the interview
process so I just went through please
check out my youtube channel and watch
the the latest video and so until
tomorrow let's have a great day